dans un château près de rome vie en
anglais dont la vie est un roman vrai à
preuve le metteur en scène de james bond
vient d'en tirer un film triple cross
l'agent triple chez lui on écoute le
disque qui accompagne le film le récit
de ses exploits gangster jusqu'en 1940
chapman est en prison à jersey quand les
allemands prennent lille alors il n'a
plus qu'une idée en tête obtenir des
anglais qu'ils effacent ces années de
prison qui lui reste à faire pour cela
un seul moyen se faire embaucher par les
allemands être leur agent secret et
pouvoir du même coup servir les anglais
ces voeux se réalisent les services
secrets allemands
le charge d'une première mission en
angleterre faire sauter l'usiné de
havilland qui fabrique des bombardiers
et prévient les anglais qui simule un
sabotage réussi les allemands croient
les usines détruites alors qu'elle n'a
pas été touché pour prix de cette
mission chapman touche 30 mai
dernière mission en 44 les allemands le
charge de repérer le moment exact le
lieu précis où tombent les béats chapman
leur donne des renseignements faux
savamment calculée par les anglais les
allemands corrigent leurs tirs suivants
ces indications et les v1 s'éloigne du
centre de l'ong chapman un agent double
certes mais surtout un bien curieux
homme d'avoir la guerre qu'est ce que
vous saviez paraît que vous saviez très
très bien ouvrir les coffres forts
c'est arrivé très bien très bien j'avais
saute fait sauter des 45 ans tous 45
autres pop
oui là haut
pas tous mais je regarde les gens
gouamene c'est à ce moment là vous avez
pris le goût d'être riche
non parce que j'étais jeune j'avais 10
ou à 18 19 ans alors j'ai fait le la bad
avec tout le vigeant dans la boîte de
nuit
j'ai une belle pâte mots je ne pense pas
de demain je veux sur mon propre
procédure laruns aimait les femmes que
vous aviez autour de vous à ce moment là
ne ressemblait pas à madame non
malheureusement
7le fille de la boîte de nuit
l'entraîneuse on n'avait pas pu les
prendre pour des châtelaines non si vous
avez ouvert 45 coffre-fort comme ça vous
pouvez vous souvenez vaguement de ce que
ça vous a rapporté c'est un gars
présents jean luc godard d'argent oui
c'est difficile parce que vous commande
de temps en temps elle avait le bijou
torride dans nous a rappelé le propos de
bijouteries les timbres poste thème
repris très difficile rappelle
aujourd'hui chapman est antiquaire ou
plutôt il a une grosse affaire
d'antiquités d'antix comme il dit à
londres et philadelphie mais il vit à
rome en vacances
[Musique]
quand on dit que chapman s'occupe
d'antiquités maintenant les gens
bouddhisme enfin voyons c'est pas
sérieux c'est une couverture sas et
j'aime beaucoup leur beauté oui d'accord
y compris ma question
oui j'avais mais ça veut dire que vous
êtes complètement rangés manuellement
comme encore plus monde maintenant je
suis ça condamné je suis content avec 50
oui alors j'avais gagné l'argent je suis
et reste avec ma vie souvent dans la
presse anglaise avec beaucoup de
discrétion puisque n'importe comment
sont obligés d'être discret ouais on
parlait à propos du train de glasgow
qu'on disait que quelqu'un qui avait
joué un rôle important autrefois pendant
la guerre peut-être ne serait pas
étranger oui ça passe en angleterre
quand les choses soit arrivé tout le
temps de police ou pensent peut-être
c'est moi et ce poste parce que j'ai la
connaissance avec la garonne stern ronde
il pense c'est peut-être moi qui arrange
tous les choses parce que j'ai la jambe
je dépense beaucoup d'argent et tout le
temps et demande d'où vous avez cet
argent elle se dit de me faire des
antiques vous avez aimé
les bruits de voix que gilles bernier ma
vie alors maintenant ils sont quant au
règlement
d'où vient cette envie de faire croire
au monde entier que vous avez envie de
gagner de l'argent moralement parce que
je suis un peu ennuyé avec les le truc
de guard tmg devenu le taulier et j'ai
trouvé les choses qui qui qui
m'adressent tous ça ne m'intéresse tout
de faire le bord de la connerie ça c'est
pour les jeunes qui sont jeunes
aujourd'hui encore vous connaissez bien
tous les le milieu des gangsters de
londres 8 très bien
elle a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup mais
dès son deuxième kiev et les bills et et
l'habileté le bel été vous avez
peut-être dix 10 ans si bien que
lorsqu'il ya un grand coup qui s'est
fait que vous apprenez par les journaux
comme tout le monde vous savez à peu
près qui en est l'auteur on préparait
bruit du canadien mais je pense à six
compagnies arabes car la bbc pas ainsi
que moi je suis non je pense que moi je
connais je pense qu une iad quand lewis
d'après m
mais je voulais dire si l'un de ces
digues angster qui sont que vous
connaissez bien et qui sont très habiles
et vous proposer aujourd'hui une affaire
intéressante pas vraiment sur
pratiquement bien que vous ayez décidé
apparemment d'être rangée est ce que
vous êtes absolument certain que nous
n'hésiterions pas un peu ça c'est très
difficile parce que ça dépend de la
grossesse de pan de le faire
ça dépend beaucoup de ça c'est une
question tout à fait dur pour moi pas
possible a répondu
pour l'aixois sur la tête mais c'est de
prendre de la terre n'est pas une
question sûrement de l'argent j'ai assez
d'argent maintenant le peut-être le
faire je m'intéresse
peut-être eu marre le fait est organisée
oui j'aime bien organiser le jeu tout en
restant assez légères la niche on
s'était comme on dit sous métro d'esprit
contre la police ait jamais donné le
très grande satisfaction professa c'est
tout je pense que peut-être ma femme
mais vaut quelque chose à dire ah oui
parce que tout le temps j les gars
étaient le fait de marcher moi dit elle
en tout cas tout nominé avec lui elle
est malade et que je suis tellement
canton maintenant du dit non posez lui
la question vous est posée
9h10 non tête nettement non pas
maintenant voyons si j'avais acheté à
dieu de l'argent ou et si j'avais acheté
un très très jolis meubles très beaux
meubles plutôt que je lis qu'ils
pourraient très très cher malgré la
sympathie que j'ai pour vous je me
demande si j'irai l'acheter chez vous et
tant d'années quand même justement ce
que je sais de ou à
oui mais je fais le métier maintenant
depuis quatre années
combien quelques années 14 ans et je le
sorcier qui avec elle je suis associé
avec énorme allons maintenant elle avait
fait 7 mai c'est le mari de madame est
labellisé pour 40 années mais ça c'est
parce que louis et n'avait elle avait
une réputation qui presque
indestructible
bridas corp ou qu'on peut gagner dit à
tout le monde c'est mon sociale tout le
monde en acceptant pour vous il n'y a
pas de rapport entre le fait d'avoir été
gangsters et le fait d'être malhonnête
ou ce qu'il y en a non parce que est-ce
que vous trompé quelquefois vos clients
depuis que vous êtes d'antiquaires
jamais vu parce que si j'ai fait ça
alors je suis allé tout de suite on peut
faire ça peut-être une boîte de foie
mais mangent exporte maintenant
peut-être demi million de livres
sterling
c'est super ça une fois deux fois vous
expliquions vous exportez oui de
l'angleterre
si j'ai fait la connerie une fois je
suis fini elle sait bien qu'on peut
voler mais on ne peut pas vendre du faux
que non c'est ça c'est ça quand j'ai
d'abord là je n'ai jamais vendu le fort
sentiment d'urgence est toujours libre
et il faut vendre et volé le vrai site
web pour pas les vrais bandits
accor pourquoi votre femme pardon
pourquoi marielle 10 est elle
définitivement tout à l'heure
puisqu'elle attend de la vie
particulièrement what have you again
cela les hypocrisies
elle est toujours content parce que nous
habitons d'angleterre autour de nous
nous verrons tout l'époque le sait nous
souriait des animaux pizza et elle elle
est toujours contre ça vous choque nous
sommes toujours honnêtes avec nous mêmes
et nous discutons en chaque nuit il
marié le faut que je fasse je parle
français
le fait que votre associé
dans la sphère d'antiquités soit son
mari vous paraît quelque chose
d'important dans la lutte contre
l'hypocrisie
oui parce que son mari c'est mon
meilleur ami youtube
il est là hop kanye jusqu'à mardi
qu'est-ce que vous regardiez bat nous
étions en train de parler hypocrisie
façon naïve
j'expliquais que la sonatel au sein de
laquelle le syndrome toute cette
hypocrisie de la vie mais entre nous
vous marie hélène roy nous avons une
complète compréhension connaissez je
vous connais nous les remercions nos
défauts et nous en discutons viola
acceptant de ska accepte ce qui vous
déplaît le plus bien hypocrisie et
malhonnête
notre deuxième pour le monde je suis mal
honnête dit xala n'êtes pas du mari
le déshonneur pour l'homicide de son nez
dans les mentalités serment j'aimerai
quand je lui posais une question poussé
il est antiquaire lui
professionnellement pouilles un grand
antiquaire à l'ordre établi
il est depuis longtemps depuis combien
de temps car quand années maintenant je
voudrais que vous lui demandiez si avant
de vous connaître
il pensait il rêvait d'être associé à
quelqu'un comme vous jamal le costume du
binôme et des dieux
elle a dit non
[Musique]